6 26 on your wednesday morning so
how about what's not driving you crazy
viewer debbie writes how about the main
road between las vegas and perhaps she
says you know what you have not
mentioned the expansion
of state highway 160 she says it's all
finished and that it looks beautiful
if you can say that about a road well
debbie i think he just did and thank you
so much for the great pictures that you
sent in
and it turns out that the nevada
department of transportation
is also taking note of the completion of
this two-year 59 million dollar project
ndot's tony ilya did not say that they
had a blast
doing the work he said they had 58
blasts
remember how we talked about all that
blasting and how you can be delayed for
upwards of two hours at a time well
tony's tidbits include these fast facts
crews used
120 000 pounds of explosive removing
more than a hundred thousand cubic yards
of what he called
stubborn fractured bedrock around mount
potency
about 8 600 drivers use the road every
day now with a smoother safer ride
debbie and tony thanks again for writing
lots more information about the project
on our website eight newsnow dot com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something that's driving you
crazy email's great and as debbie sent
in
pictures are great too our address
traffic 8 8news now dot com